We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P here
is someone accusing me of being a conspiracy
theorist and also of not being that bright.
Yeah.
So I just want to note that you, you're a
pretender very smug, pretentious person who
tries to act like you are an object and objective
arbiter of the truth, uh, that you are some
why Sage on the left when the truth about
it is you actually just engage in conspiracy
theories about speculations about Trump's
mental state and all sorts of nonsensical
things.
Um, yeah, you're not that bright and uh, God
bless you.
All right, well I appreciate being blessed
by God, but, uh, you know, most of the allegations
there are, are of course, um, uh, not true
as far as the, you know, speculating about
Trump's mental health.
Uh, I read the opinions of mental health professionals
and go by what they say of course.
And uh, as far as not being that bright well
to each their own, everybody does.
The best they can.
I think that's all we can say.
Uh, we have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about this bizarre order from
Donald Trump, which we'll have Judaism interpreted
as a nationality.
I think that this makes no sense, but I don't
even think that Trump understands what it
is that he wants to do.
Uh, we'll talk about that.
We will talk about a church nativity scene
that has gone viral.
We will talk about the word of the year from
Merriam Webster, um, all of that, and more
on today's bonus show.
I hope you'll join us,
become a member@joinpacman.com to get instant
access to the bonus show, or become a patron@patrion.com
slash David Tucker, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.
[inaudible].